hello and welcome
to pi data global 2021
my name is kevin i am very very happy
and excited to be here and to be your
host for this session
i would like to welcome
karishma babar and
kalyan
monju lurie
to our session i'm just gonna head over
to you guys so please
welcome
thank you kevin for this warm welcome at
pi data
uh
good morning good afternoon everybody uh
thank you for coming in this is our
first time speaking at pi data global
and kullan and i are really excited to
spend the next 90 minutes or so with you
all talking about the life cycle of
machine learning projects challenges
involved and how ml flow can be
leveraged to address those
challenges followed by a code along
session so without further ado let's get
started
here is an outline of the session we
begin by discussing the typical life
cycle of a machine learning project
followed by the development challenges
encountered at each stage of the life
cycle we will then introduce ml flow its
components and address how it solves the
development challenges stated earlier
we will be spending majority part of
this session implementing each component
of emerald flow for two examples the
notebook used in this session will be
shared in a short while
and we would be happy to take any
questions you may have at the end of
each topic
we would close today's session with a
recap of the tutorial and a takeaway
exercise
creating machine learning solutions to
various problems can be quite the
hardest task until recently all of us
were learning about software development
life cycle and how it goes from
requirement gathering to designing to
development testing deployment and all
the way down to maintenance we were and
still are studying the waterfall model
iterative model and agile models of
software development
now we are at a stage where we want to
leverage more
from the incoming data by means of
machine learning this new requirement
transforms some principles of software
development life cycle to give way for
machine learning life cycle
beyond the usual concern in software
development machine learning development
comes with its own additional challenges
the usual process for building an
end-to-end machine learning project
involves collecting and processing raw
data analyzing it featurization steps
training different algorithms evaluating
them and deploying the best model on
some platform for user access
it seems fairly straightforward right
but in reality it is not there are
several complexities that arise along
the way due to the circular nature of
this process
everyone who has tried out machine
learning in some form or the other knows
that there are multiple tools and
frameworks that are disposable
at our disposal for each stage of the ml
life cycle whether for preparing data
training models or deploying them in
production
for instance
data can be sourced from multiple
storage on units including but uh not
limited to amazon s3 packets dynamodb
uh as your blob storage and traditional
sql databases this raw data would then
be analyzed cleaned and processed using
sk learn pandas numpy spark modules from
bison
depending upon the problem at hand we
may either build countless regression or
classification models for contextual
visual or tabular data
finally we would deploy these models
either in docker containers or hosted as
a flask web application
as much as that is a bane for uh for us
developers to experiment with multiple
state-of-the-art ml libraries and
frameworks to get optimum performance it
is a bane as it poses multiple
challenges in tracking these experiments
reproducing the same results from the
same code and productionizing dozens of
libraries
for instance when we want to experiment
with several uh
algorithms i'll go to strategy for
tracking the hyperparameters results and
evaluation metrics for each of these
algorithms looks something like this
right
and i hope you all know it is absolutely
necessary to use the word final right
otherwise who are we you're not
developers right
the continuous nature of ml development
life cycle requires constant tracking
mechanisms to facilitate comparison and
reproduction
of results however
ml is not just code
it is code plus data that we need to
keep a track of
but that's not where the story ends
if you thought building machine learning
models was difficult
putting them into production is harder
we often rewrite our code before moving
a model to production this is not only
time consuming but also risky as it can
introduce new bugs and can lead to data
drift concept drift and infrastructure
changes that eventually result in model
degradation over time which is
absolutely normal
in some cases either the model is
retrained fully that takes a lot of time
and effort or a new model is developed
to cater to the evolving data and the
unending cycle begins again take raw
data analyze it train a model deploy it
in a nutshell
if something changes everything changes
not to forget the three building blocks
of modern maintenance and production
scale monitor and governance
while code is carefully developed in a
controlled development environment data
comes from the unending entropy source
known as the real world
thus it is absolutely crucial
to scale the model to handle large
volumes of incoming data
monitor model behavior to detect bias
drift or degradation over time model
governance is another important aspect
where everything starting from
experimentation to deployment is tracked
for auditing purposes where models are
tested for speed accuracy drift while in
production to avoid inaccuracy
this summarizes mlops it's it's a
relatively new and
exciting discipline that operationalizes
machine learning models from
experimentation to production with tools
and frameworks that are rapidly evolving
if uh this does not convince you that
mlaps is equally if not more important
than ml development maybe elon musk can
now enough about the challenges let's
dive into standardizing the machine
learning life cycle with an open source
solution
ml flow was developed by databricks and
they released its alpha version in june
2018. it is inspired by existing
customized ml platforms from facebook
uber and google with a major distinction
ml flow is open source whereas the
former
are only limited to their parent
organizations
mlflow is compatible with numerous
libraries algorithms development tools
and frameworks of python as well as r
its modular api first approach allows
you to easily integrate it with your
existing ml code base without any
significant code changes it is designed
to be platform and tool agnostic
thereby ensuring maximum flexibility for
us developers
today ml flow is compatible with
numerous frameworks including but not
limited to tensorflow pytorch keras
apache spark cyclone docker kubernetes
amazon sagemaker
uh
google cloud platform azure machine
learning and conda
ml framework ml flow framework is
utilized and contributed to by
organizations such as microsoft rstudio
facebook booking.com and many other from
the open source community as well so
feel free to read more about these
contributors and their work
on the official site of mlflow that is
mlflow.org
there are key co there are three key
components available in the open source
ml flow version
these are ml flow tracking ml flow
models and ml pro projects
mflow tracking provides an api and user
interface capabilities to ease
bookkeeping and visualization of
experiment runs and results across
different frameworks the second
component ml flow models facilitates
model serving onto a deployment tool of
your choice
last but not the least ml flow projects
allows model packaging in a reproducible
manner for cloud as well as
local platforms
let us circle back to how each of these
components address the development
challenges we discussed earlier
beginning with raw data data for a
machine learning model um you know can
be in any form of text or csv files that
can be processed either in patches
or
as as streaming data ml flow tracking
api allows the user to log various data
files used to train or test a model
additionally
tracking api can also record the steps
followed in the data preparation state
of ml life cycle that includes data
preprocessing such as cleaning data
missing value imputation followed by
feature selection and engineering and
lastly data transformation to make it
model ready
lastly
mflow tracking does what it promises it
helps you track various experiments with
numerous algorithms parameter hyper
parameter tuning model comparison and
evaluation metrics
one component ml flow tracking
that covers three stages of the life
cycle that's pretty neat right
so once we have retrieved our data
processed it fed it into a model we are
ready to solve this model in production
and this is a tricky task
integrating a model with a developer
with a deployment tool and it's the
primary avenue where majority of machine
learning projects fail and not make it
into production
himal flow models come to rescue here by
packaging models into different formats
also known as flavors and these will be
discussed in more detail in the coming
slides
in the end mflow projects ties
everything neatly together by
facilitating reproducibility and
reusability of the package model for
local and cloud execution
going deep into ml flow tracking
here are some key concepts that we want
to introduce before moving forward
we have been referring to developing
machine learning models as experiments
an experiment can be broken down into
multiple runs where each run
basically denotes execution of a piece
of code that gets logged in local files
databases or remote tracking servers
code is version while it is running from
a git repository it is important to you
know overcome the file naming problem
that we just discussed earlier final
final final
finally final and so on
the tracking api also helps you log the
project name or the source input
arguments parameters the model accepts
a record evaluation metrics of the model
such as recall precision rmse scores and
so on
furthermore this api helps you track
artifacts
and artifacts are basically files of any
format they could be
your visualization plots uh plug
roc a uc curve s k learn
pixel models data files and so on
here we depict the tracking api in a
simple schematic we can run notebooks
dot py scripts github repos directly
through the tracking api and record all
associated run details such as metrics
artifacts and visualize it in the
in the tracking user interface
now there are multiple ways to determine
where and how we can record ml flow runs
these can be recorded into local files
or to a sql sqlite database or a remote
tracking server ml pro artifacts
comprise of local files and a variety
can can be imported to a variety of
remote file storage solutions for
storing runs and artifacts ml flow
basically uses two components for
storage one is known as the back-end
score and the other is known as the
artifact score
while the back-end store contains mlflow
entities such as the run details the run
id the name of the source of the run
parameters metrics tags nodes and other
metadata whereas the artifact store
contains artifacts such as
pickled models or data files images you
know in memory objects or model summary
and so on so anything we can think of
can be dumped as an artifact which can
later be used to reproduce the run
the mflow client can interface with a
variety of backend and artifact storage
configurations starting with scenario
one this is the default approach where
the runs related artifacts are logged on
your local machine so this is the ideal
approach for standalone development
scenarios
second case based on the default setup
and stores artifacts on your local
machine while experiment run details are
logged on a sqlite database hosted on
your local machine as well
scenario three and four incorporate a
remote tracking server with which ml
flow communicates using rest request
calls at the default port of 5000. in
scenario 3 we have a tracking ui hosted
on a remote server with artifact and
experiment run logging maintained on
your local machine on the other hand in
scenario 4 we interface with the sql
database to log experiment runs and an
aws s3 bucket is used for storing the
artifacts
the these scenario 3 and scenario 4
these two configurations are best suited
for collaborative development
environments
here we have a little snippet of code
which shows how tracking can be used
with your usual ml code in the beginning
we started on by logging uh by logging
it with certain hyper parameter values
in the middle we train the algorithm as
we usually do
and last we log the model evaluation
scores of rmse and r square
ultimately the train model is also being
locked in the end
coming to the next component of ml flow
that is ml pro models the need for
emerald flow models is to provide a
streamlined channel to deploy and host
various pytorch keras xt boost
spark models on diverse deployment tools
such as as inference code on docker
batch and
streaming workflows with spark and
existing ml serving tools such as aws
age maker and azure machine learning
there can be n different permutations
and combinations between the frameworks
that a developer may use to build a
pipeline and available deployment tools
which is not very sustainable in nature
right
so mso models api provides a generic
framework to serve models in different
formats also known as flavors these
fabers can be a python function or an sk
learn function spark function and so on
the flavors the model is available in is
listed in an ml
ml model descriptor file each ml flow
model is saved as a directory containing
a ml model descriptor file that outlines
the flavor in which the model can be
used for instance any model that
supports the python function flavor can
be deployed to docker based rest server
to cloud platforms such as
azure machine learning or
amazon sage maker and as a user defined
function in apache spark for batch or
stream processing of the data
so here we have some concepts involved
in this component including flavors that
are formats modules or frameworks that
are interpreted by the deployment tools
making it easier for these tools to
understand the code without the need of
an
um of any separate integration mechanism
a model signature is a represented
representative of the model schema such
as models input and output parameters
additionally an input example is as the
name suggests example of the input the
model expects and finally a yaml file
serving as
a
as a ml model descriptor file which
outlines these flavors the model is
available in
model signature as well as the
input example
here we have a schematic of ml flow
models and its functionality that is
platform agnostic so this yaml file can
be deployed onto
a docker container or in
cloud machine learning platforms or as a
flask web app
last component is ml flow projects that
packages models in a standard format for
reproducibility
and reusability
like ml flow models mflow projects also
uses a descriptor file to outline code
environment
that is either we are using a local
environment or a conda or a local
environment the model entry point also
known as the main function
with parameters to execute
uh re execute the project and of course
not forget the project name
the descriptive i here again is in yaml
format
we have a simple schematic here again to
represent the working of ml flow
projects
component
next we have a sample ml flow project
file for your reference
we have the name the conda environment
which is basically stored in the
conda.yaml file which can be referenced
by this ml flow project descriptor file
and now we are mentioning the entry
point so our main function will be used
to
execute our model
the model expects some input parameters
uh alpha in this case where we have
mentioned the data type and the default
value for alpha and finally we have the
command which would be used to reproduce
this run
now time for some action ah i mean some
query long exercise but before we get
into actual coding exercises
uh let's get started with
mlflow the installation so these are the
prerequisites i hope everyone has python
installed on their machines
it can either be a conda distribution or
it can be python standalone uh we would
be doing majority of the exercises in
the notebook so it would be wonderful if
you have jupiter notebooks installed
if not
you can do pip install jupiter and the
other modules that we are using such as
scikit-learn pandas matplotlib and numpy
and finally
please don't forget to install uh ml
flow so you can just do pip
install ml flow in your terminal and
will be good to start
so here we will take we'll take any
questions you may have
at this point in in the basic concepts
before we move on to the coding
exercises
um
if there are no questions we can
uh yes karen
no no no no um i was yeah i'm going to
ask if anyone has any question or any
i think there's one
asking for the link for the notebook so
that's the short url that you see on
your screen
um
i can also put it in the chat
yeah that's very helpful
great uh if there are no other questions
we can uh opt for a five-minute break
and
once we are back we'll resume the
quarter long sessions
great let's let's be uh let's try to be
back in five minutes thank you
so uh one thing i particularly noticed
was when i transitioned from academia to
industry i realized what what we learn
in academia is more along the lines of
how we can develop machine learning
algorithms and how we can implement them
but we don't actually pay a lot of
attention to how we
operationalize them right take them from
an experiment stage to production
so that's that's the background as to
why we came up with this um
with this topic and why we wanted to
introduce everyone to this so even when
we are doing our site projects it's very
useful to have
um knowledge of all uh all these
concepts as to how we can go from
procuring the data to developing our
models and eventually deploy them so
they can they can drive business value
um hi can you hear me
i would have a question
regarding the pipeline sure we can hear
you going okay uh so my question would
be
um because you asked before about um you
know writing your own pipeline from
scratch and deploying it so we've been
doing that and
uh the thing that
struck me was that it's always
pretty straightforward to write a
pipeline for you know classic
applications where you have i don't know
classifier or segmentation network
but it becomes
really hard to integrate things that are
a bit more exotic like
uh you know image to image translation
with gans for example
um
does ml flow handle those things as well
or
is this outside of the scroll yeah
no absolutely so uh tensorflow and
uh keras pytorch these are all uh they
are all very much compatible with ml
flow and uh
the main problem that we experience with
actually applying deep learning concepts
is
interpretability right
uh how we are going through when we are
how we are recording and tracking all of
these experiments is usually dependent
upon
uh the print statements right in this
you can model the entire you can save
the entire model you can log all the
metrics of each and every epoch
uh and
you can reproduce them that's the most
important thing right uh if i develop
something and uh it's not reproducible
later on then it doesn't necessarily
help us
deploy that right it's not the eventual
uh goal here so it's it's absolutely uh
compatible with ml flow
oh that's crazy
yeah for for us mainly the problems are
always when
uh it's not like
uh
for example in training or training is
where the most problems actually arise
is because if you have a classic
workflow you just have you know your
input and the label
but if you have some more complex model
[Music]
then you may have a bunch of different
inputs or
you have a bunch of different outputs
and
orchestrating all of that is a bit
tricky
absolutely and not just uh
orchestrating but once you have
developed that pipeline maybe it is very
it's very much reusable across your
organization so logging that model
in ml tracking with the various uh
configurations that we just discussed it
would be very useful uh to just
distribute the code as well
so it it would be
a lost a lot less tedious to you know
maintain different models
rather than just maintaining one
and making more changes into it and
logging it as a new model so there would
be versioning as well that you can
leverage here
awesome thank you
thank you
uh yes
yeah i had one question when you said
that it is reproducible so
does it lock the format of the data or
the state of the data in which those
accuracies or maybe key values matrixes
have been achieved in order to reproduce
absolutely so those can be called as
artifacts so artifacts can be any files
you want to log it could be the data on
which you trained thank you great thank
you for your question
uh maybe a quick follow-up on on that
question
um so if you say the data is also locked
how does it handle uh deduplication in
that case because that is kind of the
most important part when it comes to
versioning data
because you typically have large files
you don't want to
uh have them several times if it's not
necessary
uh can you maybe talk a little bit
yeah of course so um i understand it uh
we could be dealing with some data
that's
something sometimes in gb right 1 gb or
2gb so logging that file again and again
it can be rewritten right so the initial
you can probably log the initial data
and then as you go through the feature
engineering
uh steps or the data
preprocessing steps you can log that
file again and again so the same
artifact gets overwritten
that's that's one way you can uh or you
can take care of that scenario
uh in case you don't want to log it
multiple times so in in a collaborative
environment we would always recommend
configuration three and four um
if we can go back to that slide kilian
great thank you
so in this case we can have a remote
tracking server where we can which
realize everything that we have logged
uh the ml experiments the artifacts and
the run details
uh these two scenarios are most uh most
suited for a collaborative development
environment such as that of an
organization or multiple developers as
well right so you can set up a separate
tracking server that's how it can be
hosted in aws for example if not uh any
other um machine it could also be in a
docker container that totally depends on
uh the use case and how we want to use
it
and the developer's preference then we
can log
all the artifacts in s3 bucket so they
can be reused again and again and
storage is not big
not not a very big problem
when we are storing it in s3 bucket
and later on the experiment details such
as i am running an experiment um i am
training uh my model on one data uh one
data file i can log those uh metrics
such as what is my last error what is
what are my evaluation metrics and
everything into our sql database
so either we can go with data versioning
of the same file again and again or we
can we can follow
um
scenario three or four
where i would say four in this in a in
this case when we have big files so
integrating ml flow functionality with
cloud and remote servers would be really
useful
thank you
so
basically uh
one last question i think we are
reaching the time
ml flow is having its own data version
in control
or we can use dvc along with it another
open source dvc for data version control
so ml flow has its
own
bbc right
yeah it does it does it helps you do
that automatically but in case you're
interested you can you can try the
integration we haven't yet though
but uh we in in all our use cases we
feel that that
ml flow itself the functionalities that
we have
uh inbuilt with ml flow they are more
than enough
cool great so over to kalyan for the
code along sessions
thank you
all right um so i hope you all if you've
been able to download
a folder that basically contains
a few set of notebooks and some data
that
is
we're working with some
model building
um so we'll start with the hello world
just to test out whether we've been
whether our installations have been
successful and whether we have all the
required libraries to basically go ahead
i'll keep an eye on the chat as well or
if you have anything any question to ask
feel free to unmute yourself and
go ahead cool so
okay the first one is pretty basic we're
just importing and checking what all
versions we have you might have some
slightly updated ones but that's
completely fine as long as
this
statement is working fine
right so help on ml flow would basically
give you all the classes their methods
and so on right so just so coming back
to the question where
where we had something on deep learning
right so ml flow by default supports
tensorflow pytorch and keras
uh so basically let you let's see
whatever model building or
experimentation that you do to export it
into a compatible flavor that you can
you know either
reproduce in someone else's system or
for your deployment approach options
that you take
in addition to that we also have very
basic
very common machine learning ones like
light gbm we have scikit-learn we have
xg boost
and so on
just wanted to highlight that um
oh no for the demo we don't need
anything
of any deep learning frameworks
installed we're just working with
scikit-learn so the idea was to keep it
introductory and basic so that everyone
could follow along but
but at the end we would also leave you
some resources that you know you could
explore
to to have a more advanced model
developed
cool um
yes that's true these are supported
uh libraries involved cool thanks
question
okay so we what if we are doing here is
basically defining the function
um and basically calling some methods
within ml flow
so
for time being we'll just leave it as as
we are setting a name for x experiment
hello world we'll dive in deep into what
each of these are in the coming
notebooks
um so you define basically a name for
your experiment
and then you use the width using the
width command you basically call the
start run method that means from here on
every execution that you do
these can be tracked or logged and then
later on visualized using the tracking
ui
so for tracking purposes we have certain
methods like you can set tags you can
log parameters you can log metrics
here we are just putting in some dummy
variables for time being just to see
everything's working
and let's execute that
and we're also trying to create a
directory where we'll see how we can use
these directories to basically log
artifacts right some of the data that we
pre-processed or some plots that we want
to
um
some plots that we want to later on uh
visualize after we finished our
experimentation purposes
and then we
stop everything with an end run command
and then
we're just calling the same function
above so it would return a run id so
these are unique to each run that you do
so
an experiment can have several runs
right you can do as much experimentation
as you want in a single
experiment that you defined in hello
world and each of those
instances of experiment will have a
unique run
and that is basically generated by the
run id
so runs can also be given a name similar
to how we have
given a name for an experiment
and that is basically done
by passing in an argument within the
start run method right so if you see it
will take in a
parameter called run name where you can
uniquely name your
runs
to distinct to the basically keep them
distinct across a
across a given experiment
right um
so just to check
um if we have the set the entire ml flow
setup working properly
i'll just basically navigate to the
location where i have my
notebooks right
so
right so this is the location where i
have my notebooks you can also
if your mac if you're working on linux
machines you can use a similar command
and for windows you can also use a
change their uh
command
i hope the text on the screen is visible
um
i can zoom in
yeah now it's visible properly okay
to basically kick off the ml flow ui
it basically starts off at a default
port called 5000
um and if you have that port empty then
it should work right but if let's say
you want to open open up it up in a
different port
you can do dash dashboard
and give a number uh
the port number that you want to open it
up
right that should work now if i just go
local host and
open the particular port
eight nine nine zero okay
so
these are all what we were running right
uh an experiment named hello world
you might be seeing some more because
these were all what i was trying earlier
but that's okay you should ideally see
hello world here in the experiment
section once you click on that you
should see all the runs uh
within that right and if you have
provided something with a unique name
you should see
the run name alongside
so that's basically a check that your ui
is working i'll take a pause here if
anyone's facing any issues or opening up
the ui
or anything
okay looks like we're all good cool um
we can close this notebook yeah relax
we'll now actually begin with the
regression example
okay uh do you have so yang if you have
install if you have conda installed can
you try installing with uh
conda the ml flow library or any can you
exactly mention which
module for which model you're actually
getting that
error
so okay i'll
can quickly share
i will actually go one by one um well
started what's the command to change the
port um
right
so
you can either give dash p
and give the port number
or you can say dash dash port and give
the port number
uh i hope that answers support question
okay looks like we already found a fix
for the module not founded so
and it looks like creating a new virtual
environment should fix it so yeah can
you can you try replicating that and let
us know if that works
okay you cannot access localhost um
so if you can't access localhost you
should see the local
ip address for your machine
uh can you try doing that
like here for example mine is 127.0.0.1
with the colon and the port number
okay so before you kick off ml flow ui
you have to make sure that you're in the
exact directory where your notebooks are
because what ml flow would actually do
is basically create this folder called
ml runs and the track and whenever you
start off the tracking server it'll look
for a
folder called ml runs
which will basically have the experiment
ids within which there will be run ids
within which
so all of these are basically what
consolidates
to the ui basically
um
so can you just
retry running the command on the current
working folder so that
and start off the ui from there
and just wait for another minute just to
make sure
everyone's on the same page
now you don't have to be on the ml runs
folder you have to be on the folder
that's on top of ml trunks
so you can basically call the ml4 ui
from pi data folder it's
um that's not going to help with the
command for windows click chain cd i
think it should be very similar cd
and then and then
path to wherever your the downloaded
folder is in your machine
in case uh your folder structure has
spaces it would be recommended to use
the entire folder
uh the folder name or the path in double
quotes
yeah in case it has spaces or any other
special characters
so that's how you can navigate from the
um
[Music]
i only see him a world and defaulting
yeah that's uh that's totally fine
so you won't see the rest of the ones
because we haven't actually executed the
code but after this session you should
see most of them
okay so um
can we partly follow and partly on a
demo
there's lots of people
yeah that's that's good
that's actually
yeah that's totally fine so if you
are having some trouble we will actually
hand over these notebooks you can
actually replicate them but in the
interest of time we'll actually move on
now that's okay i'm going to fill your
quota sites which folder is that so it's
the same folder that you downloaded
right which basically has the
the notebooks
that you just downloaded from the
from from this link
from short url from the shop
from short url the folder you have
downloaded
navigate to that folder in that folder
open jupyter notebook so that when you
see the home screen for jupyter notebook
you'll be able to see the data folder
where the data sets are stored uh and
the notebooks in that same directory so
when you run the notebook the hello
world notebook the email runs folder
will also be created in this downloaded
folder so all your data sets your
primary notebooks that we are working on
hello world or regression or
classification followed by ml runs all
these four items would be there in the
same downloaded folder
um so can you tell us tom like what's
the exact um
error that you're facing after jupiter
prompt um yes i can show you my command
prompt
okay this command prompt um is not ml
flow command prompt it's normal command
prompt it can be our anaconda prompt or
it can be our simple terminal
okay so this is a simple terminal that
we open
in that you navigate to the folder where
you have all the notebooks and the ml
run directory and from there you open ml
flow ui so emma flow ui by default as
kalyan mentioned
renders the ml runs everything that's
stored in ml runs directory so if you
want you can navigate to your email runs
folder also
navigate manually outside of cli and
view all the runs uh for hello world
that you have run
if you have run it only once only one
experiment folder would be there it
would by default be known as zero
yeah you could run it inside yeah
cool uh we'll actually start moving on
we still have quite a bit to cover um
but we'll keep taking your questions
right so right um we'll start with a
basic regression example and we'll first
execute the first set of cells which are
basically the import statements that
basically require us to execute some
functionalities right
so we basically have a regression data
set uh
downloaded from uci depository basically
trying to predict what's the miles per
gallon of a vehicle would be basing on
some eight
features uh mostly numerical
right uh and there i think there are a
few categorical as well so we'll try to
use those features and try to come up
with a prediction as to what could be
miles per gallon for a vehicle right
so you don't have to download anything
all of that
should already be there in that folder
that you've downloaded within the data
section right and you should have it as
auto npg data so that's good so these
are all uh tab separated
um
we'll start reading the data set
um
so with with the first separator of new
line we basically have two columns one
with the features and then the other one
with the call with the name of the car
right
so we'll basically expand this further
to have a column for each individual
features
and then that should have a data set
that basically lets us work on further
right we're also just checking and
trying to convert all of these
categories into numerical
um
we actually have a question
yeah so it's optional if you have if you
already have anaconda installed you
could use that
or if or just a simple python setup
would also work
yes you could do you could just run
event flow ui
yeah you can just copy this url paste it
in your browser that would work the same
way we run jupiter notebook sometimes
uh localhost four times eight so it's
the same way
yeah so we're not actually
sorry
sorry in some cases
doesn't always work for everyone so you
can use this url one two seven zero zero
one and the port
yeah we actually skipped card name okay
let's figure it out good so everything
apart from car name you're basically
making sure that everything is numerical
in nature that's that and we are
separating the dependent and independent
variable so now we have x and y's
y would be just our npg column on which
we want to make the prediction on
so it's pretty basic so far right anyone
who has knowledge in ml should follow
till here then we do a train test split
then we have an evaluation function that
basically returns two metrics the rmse
value and the
mean square mean absolute error you can
add more if you want and just make sure
you did that you add them into the
return statement as well
cool so if
let's first look at a conventional way
as in how
one would actually work on and probably
keep track of their models or
their performance of a model right so
it'll be something like this you you
basically define your hyper parameters
to start with you choose a model you put
in those parameters
then you apply the fit method then you
do predict on the test set then you'd
see what the performance is like and
then you put in print statements to
make sure that
the readability of the code right you
protein prints and see what the
performance of the model is like
or if you want to save this notebook
later on you would probably put in final
final one finally and so on like we've
seen in the screenshots earlier
right let's say if you're
going one step ahead further let's say
we're doing hyper parameter tuning
and we're doing it the old crude fashion
way right so we have basically a list of
param this list of values for alpha
defined
and we have a list of l1 ratios uh
defined with a variable called element
ratios so we loop over each of those
and every on each uh instance we
basically apply one parameter from one
element from each of those lists and
basically do a prediction
then get the evaluation metrics and then
basically print that's how we actually
keep a track of each run that we are
actually executing
right
so this is very crude way right i mean
we don't know what or it's actually hard
to basically go back and check what was
our best model
or what was
or what was the model where i was
getting this rmse and that mean square
error error or
what was the
parameters that i used for run where i
was getting rmse value as 3.2 or
etcetera right
so now let's see how ml flow addresses
that
so far so good or do we have any
questions
don't think we have cool i'll move on
right so using ml flow we start with
defining an experiment name let's call
it simpler plane regression
and then we are saying create experiment
now the reason we have actually put it
in try accept statement is basically
create experiment would run into
exception if the experiment name is
already defined
right so just to let you know that
create experiment if you execute the
same line of code again and again you
might run into exceptions so that's why
we have it accept instead an alternate
method we'll also discuss that like how
uh if an experiment is already defined
what method can you use i'll come to it
in a little bit
but yeah that's the whole idea of using
the tri except here so we have the
experiment name defined
now we are also creating an empty folder
called images it is if it does not exist
but if it's exist you can just skip
right
um
now we are doing mlfro.startrun so we
are passing in the experiment id
meaning every run that we do here
uh that's totally up to you i mean the
way you want to organize so you can
actually
make several runs with different models
in your uh
in a single experiment or if you just
want to exp in one experiment if you
won't just want to play around with one
uh model that could also be done
we'll actually come back to um how
you can better organize things right
there there are ways you could set tags
and there was you could actually go back
and search so we'll actually cover those
um
yeah so we are just
while we are initiating the run method
we are saying that everything that we
are calling under this run should be
tagged into this experiment id and we
can also give a run name
let's say
right
um cool so
here we are actually trying to simulate
the edi process with the single line of
code uh we're just plotting a box plot
for all the features numerical features
right and we are saving it to a
directory that we created above right
images
right and then we are calling the log
artifacts method so in the log artifacts
method you just pass in the directory
the location of that directory
uh where you want to log it for future
on purpose for future purposes right and
you will see how that
can be seen or accessed in the ui in a
bit but yeah log artifacts can take in
uh the path of the directory where
everything inside that directory would
be tracked for that given run that
you're running
cool
then we have the hyper parameters
defined
just playing around with some 0.02 0.15
then we are calling the elastic net
model with the same parameters
the rest of the code is pretty much same
right the conventional way in which we
are actually done in the model
the only change that we are doing is
encapsulating it with a with statement
and then whenever we're defining
something or and where we want to reuse
or re
access it later on we're just using the
m and flow methods called log artifacts
or log parents so log params is for the
parameters um
it it's basically a string a key value
pair like alpha would be the key and
this value would be the string so params
requires both of these to be strings so
even though you're passing numbers it
will be stored as strings in
in the ui in the tracking server
basically
um
then we have log metrics it's again it
it again takes the key value pairs
keys for the metric name and then the
value would be the value itself these
are numeric
yeah so you can actually use
um
ml flow dot
log metrics
and actually instead of doing it
multiple times you could actually pass
them as a dictionary with a key value
pair right
rmse
can then be
then m a e
uh you could also do the same for log
parameters
cool
and then lastly we've got whatever model
that we have built right we're using the
sk-learn flavor that we were all talking
about so till now uh and basically helps
us in
uh deploying this model for in a
platform at masterway right so if we
basically log in the model with the
flavor called sklearn
and then calling the log model method
and saying what model the object of the
model that has to be passed in and then
some name that you want to call this
model or refer to the model later on
so executing itself executing the cell
should not take much time you should see
a plot and that means the execution is
done
um
for visualization purposes that you can
also read
i mean rerun the same cell with multiple
values of alpha and l1 ratio right so
that will basically keep logging it
and see how that looks in the ui later
on
i'm just putting random numbers here
cool um i did three you can also do one
or two or three or whatever you prefer
but yeah uh i hope uh no one actually
faced any challenge in executing that
cell
looks like good good
cool um
right
we'll actually go back to the ui and see
how that looks
so if you go to the ui and and
do a quick refresh
you should see an experiment called
plain regression
right
um
and within regression you see you should
see a table that basically contains all
the runs
so right now we were we actually
ran several runs right with the name
called with the name run one so we have
three
here that have been populated
uh we'll just look at what all
attributes are covered here then we'll
try to see what each of those individual
runs have in more detail
so user would be the username from which
this particular code was executed
um source is right now a location from
the local directory but let's say if
you're running something from kit or
another repo you could see
you could see that location or that
source here and if you're using it or
any other version management you'll see
the
version for that code as well
um right so
right so we actually used a method
called log model in the end
so if that's the case we're actually
saving some model right
so if that and that and if we actually
did that in your code you should see the
flavor with which the model was locked
here in the modern section
then if you move further you will see
a few set of columns for metrics and
parameters that is so matrix is what was
the performance on the test set after
each run
both mae and rmsc can be seen you can
sort them using the column
then if you move further you will also
see the alpha and l1 ratios that we have
actually set for each run right
cool
um so now
what we'll actually do is go back into
one of these runs so you can click on
the column within start time that should
open up a page
that is different but but has more
details into the
um
has more details into the run that you
actually clicked on so tom you're seeing
only one run because you've executed
that code only once so if you try
repeating that
by changing some parameters you should
see more getting logged
if you don't see it even after that just
try refreshing the page you should see
the updated results
um
how do we run the ui so we've actually
discussed that you open up your command
prompt or terminal if you're on a linux
machine
you go to the project folder wherever
you have your notebooks
and you click and you just type memory
flow ui and this is an optional
parameter of the port if you want to
open it up in a specifically different
book
so
we jerry we only have flavor as sqlearn
because that was the model that we're
that was the model that we have built
with right so we've been actually
importing elastic net model through the
sk done package
right
okay going back so we now are in a
detailed page for a given run so we have
a date and time for which it was
run
um
we have the duration we have the status
of it finished
and if it's some reason your code didn't
execute you will say you will see some
different kind of status right you'll
see if it's in process if it's in
progress you'll see something like in
process
but uh if it if it probably ran into an
exception you should see unfinished and
so on
um
some will flow take care of requirements
see yes it does take care of
requirements of txt uh we'll just get to
that in a bit so we again see the alpha
the parameters were here the metrics
here
and some tags which we haven't actually
put in through the command but later on
let's say if you want to put something
some tag i don't know developer
then you should see these tags again
appearing in the in the original page of
the ui the landing page
cool
so now coming to artifacts right um
so
yeah so we've actually developed a plot
that we were actually trying to
visualize right and that gets locked and
that can be visualized through the
artifact section you can zoom in zoom
out and then you pop any operation that
you want to do this gets tracked with
the run that we want to that we don't
know that we have actually run
so coming to the requirements txt so
when we've actually logged the model it
takes care of what all
um
models are required for it for it to
execute properly and that gets tracked
with the
requirements.txt similarly we have the
conda yaml file that basically
gives the requirements for you to set up
an environment and you know get started
for
replicating this particular project
then we have ml model file that
basically contains the details of the
model right
and that
um so we have the flavors so python
function would be by default because of
language for choice for python function
then we have another flavor called
sk-learn because we are actually using
the sklearn package to build a model
and then we have the pickle file for
that model it's called model.pkl
then we have the sklearn version logged
in we have the python version login then
we have the rdiv through which this this
uh particular
model was locked
so
going back here you should if you
refresh you should now see
a column for tag if if you guys have
developed if you guys have added
anything there
okay i'll just go back to
questions
uh can we start uh with the question
from hong kong i'm sorry if i'm
pronouncing it incorrectly the running
column is all empty am i missing any
steps
okay can you just do refresh here that
should load up if
a run has been tracked
if you still don't see it that means
you've opened the tracking ui from a
different directory where
where the ml runs folder does not exist
so the key to have
this data seen in the tracking ui is to
have this folder called ml runs which
basically has the run details
in the ml flow run
you have that code with mflow dot start
underscore run you have mentioned the
run name there if run name is not
mentioned there that is that might be
the reason your run name column could
also be empty
awesome
name column is empty ipad
okay cool
can you also see the data version used
to train this result if you lock that
that would be visible uh maybe we can
lock that
down yeah we'll actually do that in the
next example um
i'll i'll actually come to that in a bit
awesome how is rahman asks uh how is the
pickling done we are using
uh log model.picker
we aren't using jobless we are using
because yeah we are using people here
and it's automatically done but yeah
it's typical yeah sorry
i'm sorry
uh brian wants to ask um
for nested loops we are doing it twice
is there a smoother way ah yes with ml
flow uh start run you can put nested
equals to true that's an optional
argument if you do that then multiple
runs will be recorded in the same start
experiment run
and i've also pasted the steps to launch
the ui in case someone wants to refer to
them again
perfect uh tom says he ran the cell in
notebook multiple times refreshed it in
dashboard
and i still only see the original run
um
a good way to check this would be uh can
you navigate in your file explorer or
however system you're using mac
uh can you navigate to the file explorer
and show ml runs and see how many runs
run experiments are being locked in the
same experiment under hello world you
can probably have you can have multiple
runs so you should be able to see those
that could be a good checking point
um i just think one more question around
grit search i think
yeah
yeah there's definitely a smoother way
to do hyper parameter search right you
could use a grid search or a random
search
um
we thought we'll actually
keep it as a takeaway exercise and ask
you to use
um another method of ml flow that
that
basically lets you log automatically
we'll come to that in a bit but that's
certainly doable to keep things simpler
that was the approach that you're taking
but you could definitely get that
do that
so the yaml files are basically in the
uh
the model folder the mod the folder
should be with the name with which you
have saved the module
so if you have logged the model then
only then you will see this
these yaml files
right
cool um
awesome we are good to proceed
awesome uh we'll just
go back and we'll just open the
classification example
again the data set is pretty basic a toy
data set again on cars
but it's a classification problem and
we're trying to evaluate a car within
four different categories
whether it's acceptable and acceptable
good and very good
um using various features like what's
the price what's the maintenance cost
what's the comfort
very basic stuff right so we'll again go
back to the notebook uh
import function import statements
we are basically uh
importing a decision tree classifier and
we are also using one hot encoders to
encode these
categorical features right
then
a similar method of reading this data
which is tap separated into data frames
and then we are also splitting
our
we're also splitting the dependent and
independent variables into x and y
then we have a train test split uh
method called in so to just to split the
dataset into a test sets
right so most of this is same i will not
repeat we're defining an experiment name
and that's it
um so in this particular example what
we're trying to do a little differently
is basically show you how tags can work
and how you can tag a particular run
that you are
initiating
and then
let's say after pre-processing or after
feature engineering you want to keep a
copy of your data right so in this case
what we're actually doing is we're
encoding the data then we are copying
we're keeping a copy of it
into the data processed folder and then
calling the log log artifacts method on
it so so that this gets locked to the to
the run that we've just initiated
so right
um
we started we again start with
[Music]
the start run method giving the
experiment name the run name
which is optional and can be which is
optional if you don't put anything it'll
be a blank in in the column uh in the ui
then you can set tags right to organize
your
uh
to organize your experiments or run for
later purposes right so and the way to
do it is called the set tag method you
if it's a single tag you can pass in the
key value as to what to up to element
two arguments
um both strings or if it's multiple you
can just pass in a dictionary with the
key value pair
right
then we're just using the one hot
encoder um
we discussed we have encoding it on the
train test set
then we are saving it to a csv file and
then we are logging it in as an artifact
into the data process folder
right
the next
bit is pretty common uh the conventional
approach i would say which defines some
parameters the max step is five the
maximum features is 15
and you've got you initiate the
classifier you call the filter method
there's one cool thing that
we've actually
did and we'll actually show you how that
looks in the ui but we've actually used
a package called shop
that basically brings in
interpretability uh
interpretability to the model that
you're building right
so shop
the whole idea of putting it here is to
basically showcase that ml flow can work
with several libraries uh just out of
the box you don't have to do anything
and it and not just with the code you
can you can integrate it with the other
components like the ui and so on so
we'll just come to that for time being
we've actually commented out this code
because it takes a good 10 15 minutes to
bring in that explaining ability but
what it does is basically uses game
theory uh
and the math behind it to bring in that
explanability so it could actually be a
whole different session to talk about
but for now we'll just keep keep things
simple and what we're actually looking
is
how a different package can work in time
or in
and can be integrated with them in flow
runs and
and how it works with the different
components basically
um then we're using a credit function on
the test set and we're just computing a
simple accuracy uh on the test set
then we are just logging the parameters
and the metrics like we've seen before
and we're also logging the model using
the scalar flavor
so you can
run the cell a few times
and in the end we've also mentioned some
classes right the acceptable good and
acceptable and very good other classes
right so
if you go back to experiments and go to
simple classification
i ran it twice and i have two runs here
right
um and the accuracy is 81 percent we see
the same details the run name and
everything if we go
further
to the right
we see the different parameters of this
model right the max depth the max
features
and the tags that we've set whether the
problem what's the problem type what's
the description and what's the model
type
right
cool um
if we go into the individual runs it's
pretty much the same stuff
um
going into the artifacts which are
logged here so you'll see this
encoded version of the data set both the
training test sets so sort of keeping a
copy of the data
um that that you have
used uh with some pre-processing or
after some imputations right
right then we have the model again we
see it here because we have locked the
model
the same stuff uh the
ml model file
the conda typical file and the
requirements.txt
i'll actually go back and showcase you
the run
where we've actually called in the chap
module and tried to bring in some
interpretability right
um
classification yeah
right
so
by default um so the thing that chap
would do is basically generate some
output and basically
log it as artifacts again so all of that
is automatically done with just a single
line of code and what it would log is
basically
an
a chart
that basically explains the future
importance for the different
classes and then it also has these uh
base and chap values which again uh
could be analyzed further with the numpy
package and can also be used for
plotting purposes
yeah so if you just run the code with
uncommenting you won't um
you won't
you'll see an um you'll see an error
saying no module name chap you'll have
to install it separately
uh but it will take a good amount of
time so that's the reason we've actually
not mentioned it as a pre as a
prerequisite as well
but yeah the whole point being how it
integrates well with tml from audio then
generally
uh so this is a toy data set right with
very small set of features and it took
us like 12 minutes to do that
uh so the if the data set gets bigger it
will obviously increase the time
yeah so the way to compare all metrics
one way to do it
is through this experiment page
uh one feature that we could use is
basically if we go to the regression
experiment and let's say we want all the
runs filtered
with metrics dot mae value being less
than i don't know
2.4 if there are any
they're not
so matrix dot matrix dot m a e and get
all the values which are less than 2.5
that should give me
a filtered view of the runs which have
which have this
particular performance on the mark
you will also sort in filter um or you
could also change the columns if you
think something is unnecessary to
visualize or see
we'll also see a small uh demo on how
you could actually filter through runs
and you know use them
um uh yeah how you can filter through
runs in a programmatic way
so we'll just quickly jump there keeping
the amount of time we have left in mind
and that should be in the search runs
and models of notebook
so for searching runs uh we again start
with importing two packages ml flow and
data flame
so ml flow has a
method called search runs which
basically takes in a lit an arc the
first argument being a list of
experiment ids that
you want to search on
so again experiment ids are stored as
strings so we just pass in a single
string with say zero
and that
that would basically return me a data
frame containing all the run ids
which you basically see in the ui here
right so experiment zero for me is the
plane regression
experiment that i did uh and i see all
the runs that i have here
in the notebook
right then you could also you know pass
in some queries or search strings like
you want runs which have an rmse score
of less than 3.27
and the mean absolute error
being less than 2.45 if you do that
you will see a smaller
section of the data frame being returned
you could also in the search strings
that you're passing you could also put
in additional arguments on the tags
which would you want to filter
or the parameters of the element ratio
alpha
or limit something to a particular day
of the experiment and so on
cool um so like i said it returns a data
frame so you could actually copy
everything to a data frame and then do
some of your operations
like how i'm doing here i'm trying to
filter out runs which have the minimum
mae value right and for me it's this run
and it returns the id here
right so let's say i don't have all the
details of this run id handy or i'm too
lazy to actually browse through the data
frame here what i do is actually copy
this id
and paste it here
so
to get the details of the run you
basically initiate a ml flow client
and after you do that you use the
get run method on the client to
basically get all the details here
another way to you know sort of
visualize if you don't like the ui in
any case but yeah
that's another way to do it
um
no search runs should you should pass in
the experiment id as a list uh and the
id being a number uh sorry id being a
number but stored but
passed in the string
so
here we just seeing a simple approach of
serving a model and we are trying to
deploy it as an api endpoint right
so what we do is basically pass in this
command
um
into the terminal window or your command
prompt so we're calling the ml flow cli
api
and then saying models and call the
serve method
and we're giving the model uri
so model uri is basically that unique
path for which
for the model where we have the
dot pkl model saved right and if you
recall we have saved all our pkl files
for
for the regression problem with this
name plain regulation underscore model
and it is there in the artifacts folder
uh if i can go back
and run zero
right so we have a plane regression
model and this is what we're trying to
invoke basically from this method and we
can again set a port by default which
will act as
uh where it will take in the request at
this port right
so i'll just copy this command
open up a new terminal window
right
um try to zoom in a little
and just paste this here right now
hmm okay
uh
okay just give me a second
yeah i think it's an issue with the path
yeah that's what i'm trying to fit
maybe we can go to the ui get the model
uh path from there
yup i could do that just a sec
okay we have electronics so yeah i
actually did uh
i rushed into things but what you
actually have to do is basically change
the directory to the ml runs and then
you know call this mlflow
serve method
so
uh yeah i basically changed directory to
where i have the notebooks and then i'm
just calling this ml flow serve
then that would basically
uh you know set up a
listener at this point for for some
requests and the way to actually
send a request and get some predictions
is basically
use a curl method and then you pass in
your local ip the port
the same port with which you created the
server pass on that and add a keyword
called invocations
and
the content type can have several
options uh json and so on uh we're
sticking to json here and the way
and it's structured in a way that we
first pass in the columns and define
them and what the value for those
columns are and those are
mentioned with the value with the key
called data so if i just execute this
this should return me a value for this
prediction
understand uh so that's something that
anyway everyone has to do because the
ids are always unique to your uh
to your runs that
um yeah the runs that you initiate
so yeah uh that's about model serving
um
we'll actually take up
and we actually you know take parts if
you have some questions we can take
those
um
is already included
yeah so data folder basically contains
the input data that we've been using
from the qci repo so that's already
included in the
google drive folder
so uh databricks had a good question
databx has a managed version of m flow
that basically lets you
let's some of these configurations
already predefined and it's easier to
get started on
um
yeah but it's at the core of it it's all
the same manage terminal flow just adds
a few more um
features that you know makes this makes
working with ml more seamless and
and enjoyable i'd say
thank you yang thank you raymond
thanks everyone uh before we
close up today's session i will just
demonstrate
just demonstrate if you can follow along
with the notebooks later uh the
reproducibility using a github repo so
sometimes you want to uh look at those
modules so okay and can you touch base
on that and then we will say okay yeah
so ml projects right so let's say you
want to reproduce one of your team
members work and the way you can do it
is actually use animal projects so what
i'm trying to do here let's say my
colleague has a project hosted in github
and the only requirement here is to
basically have an ml project file again
it's a yaml format file that basically
contains entry points and the parameters
that we want to the parameters that the
main function actually takes in and out
and the command basically mentions how
you take that or how do you call that
script or function uh
uh
yeah how do you initiate it basically so
it's a simple train dot py file that
basically tries to get some predictions
on one data set it's very similar to
what we have tried to execute here but
the cool thing that i want to show here
is basically you use
okay you started set experiment you
define an experiment name and you just
use the url of that kit repo right
that basically should contain the ml
project file
then you pass in as an argument into the
ml flow dot run method
and then the parameters that the script
takes the alpha and l1 ratio for example
so if you just do run it will
automatically take care of the
requirements.txt the conda setup and so
on and then just run this and you should
again uh
see it in the tracking server in your
own tracking
ui basically
so it's here the one that we just did 17
seconds ago
we know where we run it from
um
we have the all the parameters and
metrics we also have the artifacts just
the model because we're logging your
model
um but yeah that's one thing that i
wanted to show so you don't have to
worry about setting up everything for
you on your machine if you want to
replicate someone else's you also have
the source so just click on it it should
take you to the github repo you'll have
the version with which it was running
and so on that's the whole idea of using
projects like you can easily collaborate
and just pick up
uh from one of your colleagues work and
just continue from there on if the mlb
projects yaml file is different
yeah just to summarize i'll just take
one more minute i know we're already
over time so devops is basically a new
field
it's basically machine learning plus the
operationalization of protectionization
of these models so they're really
exciting but it also comes up with a lot
of pain areas and challenges right and
and we feel lemon flow is like very good
open source tool that integrates well
with a lot of these packages and modules
and lets you collaborate even further so
just doing a quick recap of the three
key components that basically
facilitators in all these
actions the tracking you can easily
visualize and track your experiments and
runs and filter them out pick up the
best run
then use that run to replicate it and
and you know package and mod mod and
package that model and you know in a
platform agnostic way and if you want to
just
transfer your project to someone else
make use of them in projects
and with the yaml file anyone should be
good to just start working on it just
one takeaway exercise if everyone's
interested to just continue where if we
left off so one cool feature is the
autolog method that basically
right now we were all logging the
parameters manually right after each
invocation so sk learn primarily and a
lot of these common libraries have the
auto lock functionality through ml flow
so mlflow would automatically take care
of logging these parameters and metrics
for each run that you do so we highly
recommend using that we have some sample
data sets all of them are classification
if you just want to play around or if
you have any deep learning example then
explore the tensorflow and keras
methods
you're
always welcome to do that
uh but yeah make sure to use the log
artifacts method and log models to you
know all these different stages of the
ml life cycle and let us know what you
feel about and what your thoughts are
after using this package
awesome
uh no sorry sorry you finished with the
reference
yeah i just wanted to highlight some
references that we found really
interesting and useful um we'll just
leave them with the presentation but
yeah and you guys should be able to
access them
all
okay
awesome uh
time is over uh
and
yeah the presentation was amazing i
think the
uh people was really happy uh was really
well presented and again we want to
thank you
uh both for the great presentation and
for being part of pi data global 2021
thank you very very much
thank
thank you for the team and thanks
everyone for joining